well it's another day in the United
States and another several mass
shootings remember even when they don't
make the news there are typically a
number of mass shootings every day in
the United States yesterday there was
one that did make national news it took
place at the Covenant School which is a
Christian private school in Nashville
Tennessee as of right now we believe six
people were killed as well as the
shooter
three children three staff members were
among the Dead the shooter has been
identified as a 28 year old former
student killed by responding police
officers and very quickly the sum total
of the narrative from the American right
wing has become that the shooter was
trans and thus everything from drag
shows to gender affirming care are to
blame oh and psychiatric medications as
well
are to blame for what took place the
shooter had no criminal record and had
attended this school at an early age
according to The Tennessean the shooter
was a trans man who used male pronouns
and immediately this is the sort of uh
reaction that we get from anti-trans
activist Matt Walsh always remember what
happened at the Covenant School remember
what happened to those innocent victims
to those children we are facing a truly
demonic evil never forget that radical
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
Greene says quote how much hormones like
testosterone and medications for mental
mental illness was the transgender
Nashville school shooter taking everyone
can stop blaming guns now Candace Owens
jumping into the mix saying when you
play Frankenstein with people's body
parts this is code for gender affirming
care that sometimes includes surgery
when you play Frankenstein with people's
body parts you can't be surprised when
they behave like Monsters a person
willing to execute violence upon his or
her own body will not hesitate to impart
violence onto someone else's linking I
guess gender dysphoria
to being violent against other people
which doesn't make any sense and has
never been demonstrated empirically Dan
bongino says quote because it has rarely
failed me I'm going to wait until I have
the details of the Nashville attack
before offering detailed comments
however after spending the past two
hours reading the absolutely grotesque
comments by leftists about this incident
and the attack on Rand Paul staffer a
sane person can only conclude that we're
dealing with demons on the left
if your sane says dan you would blame
demons there's no other explanation for
their evil none that's a very very
interesting take the now Infamous cat
turd right-wing account which has gotten
the publicity of Donald Trump reposting
their content captured posts they've
been grooming your children and now
they're shooting your children seriously
when are you going to stop being afraid
and start speaking out against evil at
what point do you stop selling your soul
to Cave to this woke mob again groomers
uh to blame Benny Johnson uh from the
right wing organization uh TP USA
Turning Point USA tweeting three weeks
ago Tennessee banned child gender
mutilation today a transgender committed
premeditated mass murder hate crime
against Christians killing six including
three little children this was an act of
demonic Vengeance by a movement of
mentally ill domestic terrorists enough
and then Laverne Spicer tweeting the
anti-christian rhetoric in our nation
has now resulted in a school shooting in
Nashville Tennessee so a couple
different things here first and foremost
there is no evidence whatsoever
that drag shows
gender affirming care
demons or any of it are responsible for
this particular shooting
furthermore it is abundantly clear that
we aren't going to prevent shootings
with things like the stop woke Act of
Florida or Banning drag shows or Banning
the amorphous CRT which they seem unable
to explain even what it is or whether
it's even being taught in classes or any
of it we do have a whole bunch of
different ideas with regard to gun
safety
none of which the right wants to
implement which would certainly help
reduce the number of these incidents no
one as I've said before no one policy
would prevent every shooting and I've
talked about before and the Gun Show
loophole Universal background checks
mandatory waiting periods no high
capacity weapons under age 25 mandatory
gun Insurance required Community Support
letters if you're buying a gun and
you're under 25 ban some weapons
periodic mental health evaluations
extensive licensing process gun buyback
program all but David the gun buyback
program wouldn't have prevented that
shooting or Banning some weapons
wouldn't have prevented this shooting
that's right but all of these things
would prevent some shootings one other
note about this I posted a tweet
yesterday
um sort of calling out the fact that
despite continuing to ask for thoughts
and prayers and saying that part of the
problem we have is God has been taken
out of school I pointed out this
shooting happened at a Christian School
this was either deliberately or
accidentally misinterpreted by some as
me blaming the kids who were shot and of
course I would never do that
unfortunately I took that tweet down
because of the number of threats that
came in not only against me but against
members of my family people finding fit
my family's contact information and
going after them so I did delete the
Tweet the point I was making of course
was that Republicans who offer nothing
other than prayers
are unwilling to implement any of the
policies I just mentioned and continue
saying the problem isn't guns clearly
this was not an issue of that given that
it was a Christian school that is what I
meant unfortunately the threats are
raining down and I did delete that tweet
for those who are asking we will
continue talking about this let's
briefly take a detour into a mom who was
able to get in on a Fox News segment
um to say when are we going to actually
do something about the gun safety issue